moi j'ai assez donné je vais donner une
42 ans donc je crois que c'est assez
pour en bois salaire moyen déjà on
survit avec donc je trouve que c'est
assez
c'est déjà assez et je trouve qui est
d'argent ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
gaspillage là on sort des millions pour
les vaccins et où on sort des millions
six mois sept mois on trouve des
milliards et des millions donc je trouve
qu'il ya de l'argent l'argent ailleurs
j'ai assez cotisé quarante deux ans ils
ont cinq ans plus parce qu'après ça
serait trop mais mais oui clairement oui
tout à fait après c'est vrai qu'on a la
chance c'est de faire un travail qui est
pas physique donc
donc oui forcément c'est plus facile
mais après si ça avait été un travail
type usine ou où le corps souffre là je
suis sûr que cinq années de plus ça
aurait été vraiment quelque chose va
honnêtement je ne sais pas mais non là
ma journée a été dure
donc c'est pour ça que je dis non c'est
par apparemment moi je serai prêt très
peu longtemps pour financer les
retraites parce que ben on vit dans une
société où il ya des personnes âgées
nous on est jeune mais à des personnes
âgées et on a des parents aussi
eh ben on aimerait bien nous aussi on
vit qui est des gens qui travaillent
pour financer nos retraites
tout simplement c'est ça la raison pour
laquelle je serai prêt et voilà
alors sur le principe ça ne me dérange
pas dans la mesure où la durée de
l'espérance de vie progresse de jour en
jour donc ça me parait effectivement
normale après d'un point de vue purement
personnelle en tant qu'auto
entrepreneurs professions libérales
soumah dire j'aurais une très mauvaise
retraite donc de toute manière je vais
travailler longtemps tout à fait non
seulement pour
les personnes qui me vont me succéder
après mais aussi pour moi puisque
normalement si je cotise plus plus
longtemps je toucherai une retraite plus
élevée
voilà bah évidemment bien sûr oui je
réponds par la pause positivement
absolument
on sent bien que ça va être assez
conflictuelle est on est on est
effectivement il faut prendre en compte
aussi la pénibilité des métiers c'est
déjà fait pour partie ça ne va pas
peut-être assez loin sur la pénibilité
des travées des travaux mais en tout cas
sur le principe d'augmenter la durée du
temps travaille pour financer les
retraites
c'est absolument indispensable alors il
ya beaucoup de gens qui vont vous dire
le contraire en disant mais non mais
c'est pas possible et cetera des
français n'accepteront jamais en réalité
les français savent parfaitement que il
va falloir travailler plus alors on
recule à chaque fois en dix ans les
français ne sont pas prêts et cetera on
peut faire autrement et c'est moi j'ai
pas trouvé quelqu'un qui me disent
comment faire autrement
la question est épineuse ce serait une
possibilité à laquelle je réfléchirai si
je n'ai vraiment pas le choix et que
l'on se rend compte que la population
est vraiment vieillissante qu'il n'y a
pas suffisamment de naissance qu'il n'y
a pas d'autres options mais à condition
qu'on me démontre aussi que le niveau de
vie est constant ou en augmentation
pareil pour l'espérance de vie le niveau
de santé également parce que travailler
plus longtemps plus pour cotiser du coup
beaucoup plus mais avoir une retraite
moindre
et arriver à une retraite où je serai en
mauvaise santé et pas profiter de ma
retraite
non ça c'est pas une super options non
c'est pas l'idéal non non il doit y
avoir d'autres possibilités d'autres
d'autres options c'est pas possible